finaliza la tormenta gélida más fuerte
de los últimos 40 años los
estadounidenses empiezan a recuperarse
de los estragos de la tormenta Elliot
con un saldo de medio centenar de
Muertos un millón 700 de hogares a
oscuras y caos en el transporte en
Navidad la mayoría de Los afectados
están en Buffalo estado de Nueva York
tras registrar hasta 128 centímetros de
nieve las condiciones de la tormenta por
supuesto se han ido pero vamos a
responder de alguna manera durante
varios días mientras continúan abriendo
la ciudad quiero agradecerles a todos
por el trabajo que han hecho
el este y el sur del país experimentaron
Este martes una subida de temperaturas
mientras que otro frente frío llegó a la
costa oeste con nieve y lluvias los
destrozos de la tormenta afectan los
planes de fin de año de miles de
personas luego de que más de 3000 vuelos
fueran cancelados desde el viernes
pasado la más afectada es la aerolínea
Southwest tras reportar fallos en el
software de programación de horarios me
acaban de decir que está cancelado y no
saldrá nada Durante los próximos tres o
cuatro días Así que tomaré un barco
llegamos el día de Navidad y el vuelo
Fue cancelado a último minuto por lo
cual tuvimos que modificar todos
nuestros planes de viaje la gobernadora
de Nueva York que informó que varias
carreteras en la zona más afectada
fueron reabiertas así como los cruces
fronterizos con Canadá por su parte el
Gobierno Federal ordenó coordinar las
acciones que sean necesarias para
retomar la normalidad